yeah speaking of around the world if we
brought it back home and we talk about
our own Safety and Security our border
has been one of the biggest topics for
every American not just Democrats
Republicans not just Texans but also
people in the north also people in New
York City who have had a flood of
migrants and now we're learning that Joe
Biden who once embraced Eric Adams well
the two of them aren't really getting
along anymore yeah that's right uh there
was a a political article titled almost
exactly that Joe Biden once embraced
Eric Adams don't expect that anytime
soon and listen to how they characterize
their relationship they call it icy the
icy relationship emerging amid Adam's
criticism of the president's handling of
the migrant crisis has evolved into a
deep freeze with the New York mayor now
embroiled in a federal investigation
over whether his campaign colluded with
foreign interest but this absolutely has
to do with the fact that Eric Adams is
speaking out about border issues when
President Biden was in New York City May
Eric Adams requested a meeting with him
and that meeting was denied yeah just
ignore by the way it should be Eric
Adams should be mad at the president uh
it should have vice versa because this
president's irresponsible way of not
handling the Border issues has caused
the sanctuary city in New York which
should never be and the right to shelter
which should never be in place has been
overwhelmed by with over
130,000 it's estimated 85,000 are still
here they're coming at 2,000 a week and
this is a little about what's happening
outside the hotels with they staying for
free getting three meals a day getting
their laundry done and getting their
sheets changed all at our expense to the
point you got to cut back they have
chosen to cut back cops cut down Library
hours cut back FDNY cut back Educational
Services because we're doing all this
for free because of President Biden's
irresponsible lack of Border policy and
is destroying one of his the city that
one of his greatest supporters runs why
is he mad at Eric Adams for speaking up
speaking saying what everybody knows he
should actually be more direct yeah you
you know this goes back to what we
talked about in the beginning of the
show about this idea that Biden's
Administration puts out these talking
points for Thanksgiving that says Trump
didn't shut down the Border Trump didn't
make the Border any better all he did
was put families in cages I don't
remember a couple of years ago New York
being at odds with with the with anyone
in the in the the with any of the
leading Democrats over what should be
done about the Border but here we are
with a democratically a Democratic mayor
in New York and a Democratic president
in the White House
and for some reason they can't get on
the same page so if it's all about
ideology and all about how bad Trump was
then why do we have this problem in New
York right now I do not know how you
sleep at night if you're President Biden
or secretary Alejandra morcus with a
wide open border during a heightened
Terror alert because of what's going on
in Israel uh with Hamas and knowing that
you can change it politics comes into
play here big time but if you're the
president of the United States national
security is your top priority right uh
and by the way people say why is Donald
Trump winning why is Donald Trump
winning because the issues he ran out in
2016 are even more appropo today we saw
the way he handled it compared to way
President Biden's handling it and a lot
of Independence a lot of undecided are
saying I like the old way and maybe we
should have pushed judges to do what
Trump wanted that's get rid of the
sanctuary City status declared
unconstitutional I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angy aart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analys
is